you weren't setting out to write a
bachelor book there's definitely some
tea in there there's tea i wanted to get
my side of who i am and what i've been
through out there
all right matt i got a chance to tell
you that i did read the book yep it also
just explained like why you are the way
you are why you did the bachelor i also
know that you had a huge influence in
that decision because before you even
named the bachelor you actually passed
on the bachelorette multiple times yeah
but it was your friend tyler cameron's
mom that convinced you yeah what do you
think she would say if she could see you
today
man i think she would just say that
she's proud of us you know myself and
tyler included because this journey
wouldn't have taken place for me if it
wasn't for tyler taking that leap of
faith and me seeing the reform man that
came back from that experience
hello
the women are literally falling for you
so then
instead of the bachelorette you are
named the bachelor and with that the
first black bachelor uh you mentioned
the book that there was a point where
you felt like you feared you were going
to be tokenized by the network or by the
show how social you know there hadn't
been someone like myself stepping into
that position and with everything that
was going on in the country at that time
i wanted my experience to be raw and
truthful to my experience and not what
someone thought that experience should
look like or what someone thought
someone in my position should act like i
wanted it to be shot
authentic
love for me
is about the heart and they're not a
color you can put on that it's fine
you know you also explained that you
weren't bachelor nation like you didn't
watch the bachelor of the bachelorette
you know that wasn't your thing and yet
you still signed on to do it
i'm curious would you have said yes to
becoming the bachelor had you been a
little more familiar with the franchise
uh
i i would have because i
and and it's only off the context of the
people that i had conversation with the
sean lowes of the world ben higgins you
know my homie tyler cameron having
conversation with rachel lindsay like
people that i respect as humans before
them being a personality or figurehead
um those type of conversations were like
dang like this is something that
i can see personal growth i'm happy
where i'm at you meet the love of your
life rachel of course we all know the
controversy we don't have to relive it
now but what was it like for you to have
to relive it though in this book and was
there any part of you was that was uh
afraid or hesitant to share too much
when it came to your relationship and
and that fall out from that yeah i mean
you're walking on eggshells when you
talk about that stuff because it's it's
real yeah and uh
i i wanted to make sure that when i'm
uh expressing our story rachel and mine
because we went through that together
that i was in constant communication
with rachel when i'm sharing how she
wants that
the feelings that i have for you
don't go away overnight
um you know a lot of people had opinions
on your relationship with rachel before
those photos even surfaced you kind of
mentioned that earlier do you feel like
your relationship with rachel is getting
more support these days though at least
publicly i think as people get to know
rachel and i better than they understand
our relationship you know in the context
of a show and how it's presented there
you know it doesn't give a full picture
and it's not their job to give that you
know they can't present everything so as
we continue to live out our lives i
think people see that we're real
authentic we love each other and it's
not for show you can tell from
you recounting falling in love with her
that it is the real deal and that's i i
feel like that's what brought you guys
back together is true love so now i'm
curious like are we thinking about a
ring are we talking about engagement
like is that where we're at
that's the real deal who puts you up to
this
where's rachel i'll say this i'll say
that at this point in my life i wouldn't
be dating someone or with somebody that
i wouldn't consider
marrying so that's that's the end goal
and that's what we're working towards i
can't propose to you today
but that doesn't mean i want to lose you
i'm curious though like as you were
writing it you know what was the hardest
part and how did you feel now that it's
out and like on paper
danny i would say the hardest part was
actually going on the show because you
know um
i had my doubts if something like that
could work and i'm fortunate that you
know i put those aside because i'm in a
great relationship now with rachel but
um i'm like can i really put myself out
there and be vulnerable enough to let
these women in on the things that i've
been through because i've had a crazy
life right and i have a crazy family yes
but
everyone has a crazy family and
everyone's been through crazy stuff
speaking of of your family
your mom is featured in this book
she supported you at the boston marathon
oh yeah it's not right she's a
ride-or-die huh she's she's a real one
well you dedicated this book to her and
we know that rachel says she cried
reading the book but what was your mom's
reaction
you know
there's a lot of things in the book that
my mom i hadn't shared with my mom
before yeah so she was reading a lot of
that for the first time especially from
a standpoint of how i felt
being
the product of a mixed relationship i
think a lot of that went under the radar
because she's so busy working obviously
the book also goes in depth into your
childhood you're evolving a relationship
with your dad which by the way you know
america was introduced to him in one
scene on the bachelor and of course
there was some controversy around that
no one is perfect son
look around you in this world who is
perfect i'm not perfect you're not
perfect yourself
um what's your relationship with your
dad like today we have a great
relationship yeah and i think that again
without the context of what my dad's
been through not to give a lot away but
i mean his father was murdered and
the things that he brought into the
relationship with my mom and through his
childhood was so traumatic and i didn't
have context to that so as you gain
perspective of things uh my empathy and
compassion for
the way things were handled changes
whatever i can do to make it better
i'll walk on it
because i want you to be happy to forget
your life and i want to have a
relationship that's healthy and
not like what i went through so through
the good and the bad of this experience
it doesn't feel like a sour journey to
you
i'll say this i'll say that
it's a shame that
there's the amount of people that go
through this experience with that sour
taste in their mouth because i feel like
it doesn't have to be like that
but that being said you have to make
sure that the show that you're
continuing to build out caters to the
audience because if if you're having to
you know
do circus acts and trapezy stuff to get
you know strum up this like fake height
then like maybe you should get back to
the basics and there's other factors to
consider i think is what you're also
saying about like you know
what you're going to say yes to exactly
cheers to falling in love
all right so this book covered the first
30 years of your life matt what did the
next 30 look like for you the next 30
years oh that's a great question um
a lot of personal growth and a lot of
giving back and getting into the
community because through the pandemic i
saw that's where my heart and my passion
is is the people i saw how
the mental health and the physical
health took a toll on people during the
pandemic
i feel a responsibility knowing what i
know to do better and serve those people
who were who were affected by it
[Music]
you